c'était fans et g ans émilie nicolas
christian dufour bonsoir bonsoir bonsoir
le port de montréal j'en parlais avec le
ministre boulet tout à l'heure c'est une
artère extrêmement importante pour
l'économie du québec
et quand elle est bloquée mais tout le
monde était sous flip lille je suis con
a connu des essoufflements contenu de
l'accord est dans une classe à ce repas
conflit de travail qui vont nous
replonger dans des dans des affres
économique
or il ya un jeu de négociation alors où
vous en êtes donc d'abord je vous faire
entendre parce que toute la journée ce
qui était pas avec nos débuts l'émission
toute la journée à ottawa on s'est
positionné devant la loi spéciale
peut-être sera adopté demain on est
content je les y la première grève au
point qu'un vernis que ce serait des as
économique pour nos pme projet de québec
notarié aussi évidemment je préfère
beaucoup un contrat négocié que
d'imposer une loi spéciale y ait aucun
doute nom de l'harmonie la mesure du
possible je pense que signifie pour moi
sa palme d'or spéciale serait la guerre
perdure
le consensus au québec pour qu'on
intervienne pour faire reprendre des
activités du par le gouvernement du
québec le nombre des tous les
intervenants le demande parce que des
milliers d'emplois sont en jeu la chaîne
d'approvisionnement est en jeu la
crédibilité la réputation du port de
montréal est en jeu
c'est important d'avoir une solution
bien sûr parce que liane risque grave
pour notre économie avec une grève a
pour beaucoup de jours
la solution pour qu'il n'y ait pas de
grévaux par ce n'est pas une loi
spéciale laquelle est un aveu
d'incompétence et de manque de
leadership
c'est deux coups de téléphone l'autorité
du premier ministre au monde
fini les niaiseries gérer différentes
ligues un problème pour les travailleurs
travailleuses
ils ont le droit de régler ce problème
eux-mêmes sans avoir l'intervention du
mouvement libéral au document fédéral
le npd qui s'opposaient loi spéciale le
bloc québécois et les conservateurs qui
serait plutôt prêts stéphanie grammond
est-ce qu'on doit tout de suite mettre
fin à ce conflit de travail de demain
moi je pense effectivement que le
fédéral et que là il y aurait peut-être
eu d'autres moyens plus souhaitable à
mettre en place mais là on est rendu au
point où on est et oui effectivement je
pense qu'une loi spéciale ça va ça va
être de mise
et même il faudra voir plus tard parce
que loin spécial c'est un peu comme un
dieu selon qu'on m'ait serait sur le
bobo mais après ça si on fait que les
conditions de travail ça sera pas une
éternité
donc est-ce qu'on veut jouer encore dans
le mélodrame dans peut-être deux ans je
ne pense pas donc faudra penser aussi à
des solutions plus permanente plus
structurantes pour éviter qu'on se
retrouve toujours dans les confits ni de
travail au port de montréal avant de
poursuivre je souligne qu' il ya des
demandes patronales qui ont fait bondir
le syndicat c'est à dire d'être
disponible un peu plus avec plus de
jours de suite
le salaire moyen est au tour selon le
patron de 125 1000 $ par année emilie
nicolas est ce que on peut se permettre
de laisser le jeu de la négociation se
poursuivre c'est le fait qu'elle soit
menacée comme en fait nuit
des gens me contactent on offense ou
assis le pain du corps c'est que s'ils
continuent à tenir son bout tu vas avoir
une loi spéciale nécessairement fins et
a bloqué avec les négociations n'ont pas
maman pendant que cela parfaitement
c'est que ça peut tenir son bout qui
peut pas négocier parce que de toute
façon pas important 5 une attention que
l'employeur finalement quant à son goût
donc il ya quelque chose déjà qui rend
la négociation sur la face du parking
qui était dans cet état vous parle ce
copilote ont dit à vos nuire à
l'économie ce qui est vrai mais ce que
ça fait paradoxalement c'est que plus
que les travailleurs sont essentiels -
ils ont besoin millions de moyens de
négocié l'accord de son travail dans spe
coty c'est pourtant le falher qui est un
jeu qui est vraiment la question des
horaires la question du de commissions
l'employeur veut allonger le nombre de
jours disponibles pas sali le c'est 18
de ses 19 qu'on demande bref mais
christian ça pose la question est ce que
ce n'est pas dans le fond pour une
économie comme la nôtre un service
essentiel que de recevoir les les
conteneurs dans le port vous lisez dans
mes pensées
oui je pense des valeurs de vous et
c'est vrai je vais commencer par ceux
dans les fêtes les débardeurs du port de
montréal
bon ils ont le droit de grève qui a été
accordé très largement dans la société
mais ce sont des travailleurs essentiel
donc un côté jusqu'à l'entêtement
inévitable dans ce film là en fait qu'on
a vu à plusieurs reprises
moi je ne crois pas que les travailleurs
n'ont aucun pouvoir de négociation parce
que pour un gouvernement à adopter une
loi spéciale c'est pas évident c'est
agréable c'est pas
facile donc ils ont le droit de grève là
ils ont décidé quand même de faire une
grève illimitée massivement je vois pas
quel au choix le gouvernement a que de
faire adopter une loi spéciale puis
d'imposer un mécanisme d'arbitrage dont
les débardeurs ne ressortiront pas
nécessairement perdants parce que
rappelant qu' on n'est pas en face de
damnés de la terre là c'est pas le
germinal d'emile zola
c'est un salaire moyen de 125 mille
dollars le sait sont comme les
aristocrates du port de montréal dont il
faut quand même relativiser tout ça mais
je vois pas comment ça peut être
autrement dans la mesure où lyon udraw
game mais ce sont des services
essentiels marqué science comparé aux
travailleurs parfois enfants d'emile
zola puis de germinal
tout le monde est gras dur mais en
comprimés gala mais 125 1000 $ vous
avouerez patrice ça ferait pleurer tous
les québécois
mais stéphanie donc j'en parle en
bénéficient de cette décision qui avait
déterminé il ya quelques temps que
c'était qu'ils n'étaient pas des
travailleurs essentiels qui vient un peu
faussée l'équation parce que dans le
fond vous connaissez bien l'économie
c'est un service essentiel non bah oui
parce qu'on le voit bien là ça paralyse
toute l'économie au complet dont ils
tiennent un peu en attendant qu'ils ont
un pouvoir de négociation qui est quand
même énorme
et face à eux le syndicat qu'ils ont ce
qu'on sait pas nécessairement c'est que
le port n'est pas l'employeur employant
c'est une association de d'employeurs
martin qui sont un peu mort seul hic ce
sont même des concurrents donc de la
partie
la contrepartie qui négocie avec le
syndic heures et parle pas les errements
d'une voix forte
alors ça donne un drôle de rapport de
force moi je pense effectivement que oui
c'est vrai il ya eu cette décision-là en
cour fédérale qui dit non ce n'est pas
un service essentiel d'ailleurs ça a été
portée en appel donc en ce moment c'est
devant la cour d'appel fédérale
ça pourrait changer les choses mais même
si le jugement était maintenu il ya un
hic empêche le gouvernement ensuite de
du bon allende encore nous on va
décréter que c'est un service essentiel
et d'ailleurs ils n'ont fait en 2010
pour les produits qui vont interne
donc ça c'est vraiment considéré comme
un service essentiel tout comme les
produits est céréalier à sao part c'est
essentiel mais le reste ne l'est pas moi
franchement je pense que ça devrait
l'être
et puis ça éviterait que on se retrouve
toujours avec un mélodrame à chaque
négociation gens mais on vient les et
christian oui je comprends ce que dit
stéphanie mais moi je pense à deux fois
avant de leur enlever leurs griffes
parce que c'est quand même un droit
assez fondamental et je défendrai que
seulement le système actuel je sais que
ça peut avoir l'air tout croche
on est dans une négociation dans des
rapports de force
moi je le répète je trouve qu'ils sont
pas sans pouvoir de négociation les
débardeurs par ce qui mobilise toute la
société puisqu'elle haifa docteur projet
de web le npd va les défendre ça mais en
même temps c'est dans la nature des
choses que ses 1150 travailleurs ne
peuvent pas prendre l'économie en fait
en partie du québec et du reste du
canada en otage donc dans le même ça
fait croche de ce thème actuel dans la
mesure où ça chacun fait sa job ne me
sens pas si dysfonctionnelle dans les
fait d'accord alors on suivra demain
mais sa rivale et vt mille-îles sa
réserve d'aller vite demain parce que
les conservateurs vont appuyer les
libéraux nature oui donc de passer si
c'est la volonté du gouvernement
ceci lui reporter le problème fait
depuis deux minutes je parle 2018 par
donc là la convention collective est
échue
donc si on n'arrive pas à s'entendre on
n'arrête pas d'entendre encore une fois
mais c'est les questions au fait des
questions de race et les questions comme
son travail moi je trouve ça juste
intéressant le récit collectif selon
lesquels cela pour des travailleurs
comme les gardiens en otage on pourrait
toujours se dire que c'est la situation
et des employeurs qui parle économie en
otage en particulier de travail moi
c'est plus une question là que je crois
que pouvait on se pose des questions
parce que sinon on va tout déclarer tout
le monde est essentielle puisque
nécessairement le but de la grève se
déranger ceux d'avant doute pas que son
économie ses souliers
abordée il ya un parti un peu tout à
fait tout à fait ok très bien
il était dernier on faisait des lices le
syndicat disent nous on va faire passer
ce qui est essentiel c'est à dellys
l'ampleur s'entendaient pas sur les
listes plan n'ouvrait les cons ça a été
le mec mac total bon qu'ovide les qu'au
québec on a vu le on a vu le tableau
aujourd'hui ça se stabilise au québec ça
c'est en baisse même cette troisième
vague on verra on n'est pas de 20
personnes
mais en ontario on voit les chiffres du
québec tout le positif très bas alors
voilà ça c'est un fait en ontario c'est
tout un autre une autre histoire 19%
trop de possibilités et on demande à
l'armée
et d'ailleurs on a la réponse qui vient
de tomber à quelques minutes de bill
blair qui dit oui très bien vous entendu
et on va envoyer des infirmières on va
envoyer des du personnel médical de
l'armée
c'est voilà le l'extrait du communiqué
du ministre à la sécurité publique
stéphanie deux réalités et on a connu au
québec celle là aussi dans le pire des
vagues
c'est difficile à concevoir parce qu'on
n'est pas si loin mais on est pour
l'instant assez loin quand même
oui bah tant mieux on souhaite que ça
que ça traverse pas de notre côté mais
enfin si l'ontario a demandé l'aide de
l'armée
et puis ça a été quand la au québec et
en ontario d'ailleurs la première balle
on se souvient que l'armée est venue
dans les centres de soins longue durée
allant y avait des il y avait des
soldats qui qui peignait les cheveux
d'une vieille dame mais qu'est ce que
c'est bon si c'est ça que ça prend 1,6
et de nourrir les gens si c'est de
changer des couches chez terrain mais il
faut ce qu'il faut puis tant mieux si
l'ontario peut avoir du renfort
j'attendais aujourd'hui en fin de
semaine beaucoup d'experts des
attentions même au québec
faites attention ne pas
ne pas tout de suite assouplir les
mesures parce que ça peut repartir assez
vite
emilie nicollin christian dufour ya
quand même des pressions pour assouplir
les mesures je pense notamment aux
parents dont les écoles pour leurs
enfants sont toujours fermés la québec
lévis gatineau ml oui c'est sûr que
cette façon le beau venir puis je pense
que du côté de youtube et j'espère qu'on
allait rouvrir si c'était possible
l'école primaire donc ça devrait venir
si elle met toute la campagne de
vaccination avant l'autre mesure qu'on
suit est contestée la question reste
pure avec arts à montréal d'ailleurs je
pense que les partis d'opposition
avaient mis de l'avant une motion pour
que l'institut de recherche en santé
publique
puis les études montrant le lien entre
le couvre-feu puis la base des chiffres
appuient donc pour le moment refusé que
la soi-disante a donc cette mesure qui
reste parmi les acquis qui tombe mais
c'est en même temps elle esquisse pas
qu'on n'a pas nous extrêmement grave
je pense que la proximité avec avec les
gouvernantes mais pas avec les
gouvernements mais avec la société là
bas fait en sorte que lorsque les gens
qu'on craignait que la trop grande vague
c est très sérieuse que si ça vaut bien
ici un ensemble de raisons pour
lesquelles peut-être ça vaut mieux
porter quel virus a déjà tout le monde
sait qu'il est collective ceci dit pour
toujours au dessus et faire attention
jusqu'à tapoter vaccinés oui parce que
christian et laissez moi qui lis dans
vos pensées de foie si j'allais dire ben
là quand ça va bien
au québec on dit oui mais ça pourra
aller mal quand ça va mal mais l'on
resserre alors on dessert jamais on a
quand même des séries mais est ce que
quand même
l'exemple de l'ontario ne nous pose pas
une grande prudence face ou forcément
c'est clair que l'ontario flèche que
certains points partie du paysage
québécois
ça se réjouit d'aucune façon des
malheurs de notre nos compatriotes trop
tard et on peut être pour l'écho des
québécois vaste un retour des choses
parce que quelques mois est un peu en
hauteur de notre performance au sein du
canada on voit que nous
c'est nous qui faisons souviens c'est
plus facile de perdre des libertés que
des rires père et c'est très clair pour
le gouvernement du québec se passe il
c'est bien parce que l'ontario et la
viola pair ou impair en fait que
l'ontario se mettent à déborder puis que
ce convives se sont une espèce de petite
parenthèse qui va bien mais que ça n'est
pas bien aussi longtemps que ça bon le
couvre-feu bon c'est le bébé de monsieur
le gauche qui en certains points mais
bon on semble croire que ç'a un impact
gens le pensent même si c'est pas
vraiment trouvé mais à mesure ta belle
saison ce s'accentue peut-être pour un
médecin 9h30 aussi un autre élément
une part qui présente qui l'était moins
et quelques mois elie des registres
internes ce que j'étais le dirigisme
terre est solidement installée lors une
idéologie aussi lot au juste des
scientifiques des politiciens on est
dans le risque zéro donc pour monsieur
legault ce qu'en pense et c'est bien moi
personnellement je m'engage pas dans
l'eau jusqu'à 0 l'a donc j'aimerais
quand même qu'ils relâchent un peu mais
il va faire attention parce que l'on le
monde compte harriet à côté c'est
surtout le monde y pense paul italy's
pas la france parce qu'en france quand
il a grande bretagne que ça allait mieux
la france c'était épouvantable
mais là c'est sa liste à côté là donc
les gens se disent attention quand même
on n'a pas envie de revivre une autre
montée en tout cas annoncé c'est certain
que personne n'a envie de rejouer dans
le même film
et puis c'est sûr qu'il va y avoir des
pressions là aussi c'est qu'on continue
à diminuer au québec pour des
assouplissements mais de mon côté je
pense que le gouvernement legault va
pouvoir facilement j'ai regardé ce qui
se passe chez nos voisins la ccpo le
temps d'aller trop vite et plus de deux
semaines encore à risque noté win
c'est juste à côté c'est juste de
l'autre côté de la rivière on n'est pas
non fériés ou la légende à moi je
comprends que on veut revenir bon par
exemple dans les écoles les fonctions et
saufs à la maison le depuis plusieurs
semaines
mais oui non c'est pas drôle mais d'un
autre côté on doit être plus d'un qui
l'exemple de ce qui se passe en ontario
va certainement aider le gouvernement à
maintenir d alinghi week anciens moins
de choses qui commence à m'inquiéter
c'est que de plus en plus à cause de
l'idéologie
senneterre on reporte les échéances on y
disait mort des lycées la vaccination
qui la clé pour ce faire il entend de
plus en plus de gens nous disaient non
non il faut que ce serait que partout à
la grandeur de la planète pour qu'on
puisse recommencer à vivre normalement
je lis ça et j'ai entendu des gens
crédibles qui devrait comme un problème
mondial des bulles oms est certain que
tout le monde ne sera pas bien on ne
prend pas totalement bien aimé laffon
mesure évidemment exactement
emilie vas-y mais je le fais parce que
je crois par idéologie sanitaires quand
même fait chance 24 fois que son
gouvernement début de la pandémie
orphée refusent de voter pour avoir des
congés de maladie payés pour les
travailleurs est essentielle
ces mesures qui écoute et par
l'opposition que les conservateurs bloc
même avec les chiffres sont là il y
aussi des questions en ce moment bon ils
viennent d'envoyer l'armée déjà du jour
du parlement fédéral leur voilier dans
le port pour des raisons partisans
voulaient pas venir chercher sans l'aide
des provinces conservatrices donc il ya
un enfant politique en période de
leadership the way en venir là on va y
revenir emilie merci beaucoup ses fans
emilie christian merci encore une fois
ce soir bonne soirée en voyait revenir
c'est sur bercy pour voir nos émissions
en entier rendez vous sur la chaîne ici
et redit